ils se sont rassemblés en nombre dans ce
hangar les distances de sécurité rendue
accessoires le temps d'un douloureux
exercice l'adieu à un camarade tous
ensemble collègues ambulanciers pompiers
réunis pour un poignant hommage
c'est ça depuis samedi nous attendons
que tu rentres à la base nous avons donc
tu reviens qu'on nous rase ou dès que tu
nous parles de ces vacances qui arrivent
qui pourrait emmener dans le sénégal
parce qu'on éprouve des enfants la
famille moussa c'est la première fois
que tu rassemble des personnes pour les
faire pleurer c'est la première fois que
toi le gars discrète il retrouve sur le
devant de la scène
puis autour de ses proches d'évoquer les
rêves faucher de moussa qui s'imaginait
un jour infirmiers
les visages sont graves et les mots sont
dérisoires souligne la ministre déléguée
à la santé face à un cortège d'élus
brigitte bourguignon venu au chevet de
la profession soyez assurés que la
légion d'honneur à titre posthume sera
attribuée à moussa vient en signe de
reconnaissance de la nation
son engagement aux oblige et la
république ne l'oubliera pas c'est
précisément ce qu'espère l'audience ces
héros du quotidien comme les a encore
rappelé la ministre attendent plus qu'un
titre symbolique
[Musique]
il faudrait qu'on soit reconnue
non mais on n'a pas eu la prime que
vides il ya un temps pour placer leurs
noms mètres français
voilà ma chère maman
ce métier il aime mais l'exercent de
plus en plus souvent avec la peur au
ventre
indispensable le statut reste ambigu on
fait partie du ministère des transports
alors que quand j'ai fait l'école je
suis diplômé du ministère de la santé
donc je pense que le réel problème il
est là il ya de plus en plus de misère
sociale et on y fait face tous les jours
il ya de plus en plus de détresse
psychologique locaux vides l'a accentuée
et c'est ça qui rend les missions de
plus en plus compliqué
après le recueillement viendra le temps
des actes politiques tous espèrent que
le sacrifice de leurs collègues moussa
dieng ne sera pas vain